Stephen A Smith is here Michael wilbon
is here from ESPN guys it's it's been
fun being on your show earlier you guys
were on ours and and thanks for sticking
around even though you're not working to
be on this show tonight it is an honor
and a privilege to be with y'all uh
especially and listen everybody up here
has been a brother of mine for the last
20 years I mean I don't like to admit
this to much but I love y'all I love the
hell out of y'all so it's just it's just
good to be here and I just I said this
earlier I just want to thank Mike for
being a friend a mentor you and a mod
have always been there for me I get yall
advice on all my business I want to say
thank you I love you brother first and
foremost and let me tell you something
Stephen this is a warning this is a
promise if you mess with any of my boys
clothes like you be going at Daman Woody
who does a great job in Ryan Clark If
you say anything bad about our clothes
it's going to be some damn furniture
moving up here you ain't scared me you
better watch your mouth I'm not going to
take this from you tonight and I also
want to say thank thank you to Mike
willb and stepen cuz remember how how I
said I was getting 20 points off of my
talent these two brothers pulled me to
the side and said you're not playing
hard enough and this is what I'm going
to write let me I say this Charles I get
to see all the time and I love him like
a brother literally I've never really
thanked Shaquille enough there were
times I he was the last guy out of every
locker room cuz I was standing there
bothering with a newspaper with a
notebook and a pen and times in Miami I
was down there for the Super Bowl and
Shaq would stick around and help me with
with pieces and the the career can't be
what it became without that sort of help
trusting me trusting us uh and what we
did Shaquille and you and Kenny and
Charles I get to at least tell this all
the time CU we hang out in Scottdale but
but both of you thank you well we're
giving out thank
yous and we're going to give out some
history cuz Stephen A Smith and I go way
back to the fact that he played for my
brother Vince he played what he play
play basketball fo wait let
me have tapes back there I'm going to
give you I'm going to give you the
rundown because my brother helped them
get a scholarship to college so wait let
me tell you this you got a basketball
scholar yeah they see how you
lying just going Li TT
quit hey shot here's the rundown he
could shoot it right he could shoot the
basketball defense was a little
wavery but he's the only guy who wrote a
bad article about his own college coach
while he was playing while he was
playing on the team so did you really
yes he
was was in the right place was in the
right on the team Chuck my was my heart
was in the right place I was looking out
for him wasn't that article something up
to the effect of is he the right man for
the job you were you were scholarship it
was actually it was actually he needed
to
retire big house games of in the right
place
issu issu he had health issues man Hey
listen listen my brother called me like
yo you know the Stephen a dude Stephen A
yo he wrote an article about big house
and he gave him a scholarship talking
about he don't he's the right not the
right man for the job oh he was the
right man for the guard then there he
is oh my goodness that right there are
we not supposed to be talking about NBA
basketball we not supposed to be talking
about we just watch dude we just watched
the for BL what the hell we going to say
here's what we can talk here's what we
can talk about oh already did it is the
fact that on Saturday it's the
championship game it's the Pacers and
the Lakers it's on ABC why don't you
guys handicap that game for me and then
we'll do a little bit more fun with
first just a comment I'm really
surprised cuz I agree with Shaquille
before the game that Zion we thought
this would be his night this was the
most notable game was there pressure
Maybe not maybe he felt some but guys I
was really surprised at the tone of that
game the give up the lack of competitive
spirit I wasn't cuz I I think that New
Orleans when healthy can challenge
anybody in West I'm not saying they can
beat everybody but but he's got to be
right that that was embarrassing because
we talk about it all the time it's hard
to lose the NBA game by 20 points that's
right and if you got but when you lose
by 40 you give up and they gave up
tonight and that was embarrassment but I
was telling Shaq and K and Earnie before
LeBron's the oldest guy in the league
looked like the youngest guy on the on
the court tonight it was beautiful to
watch some fire it it was beautiful to
watch but there's a flip side to that
when you're 30 when you're approaching
39 years of age in your 21st season and
you're consistently going into an arena
night in and night out and you're not
just the best player but you're the best
conditioned athlete it does make me look
at the younger guys and say what the
hell are y'all doing with y'all time you
get paid enough money to take care of
your body to be in PE condition to be an
elite physical shape and so when I look
at LeBron James performing the way that
he performed it makes me think about
Anthony Davis and I'm going to stay on
Anthony Davis all year long joic is the
best player in the world in a lot of
people's eyes they swept you last year
you talk smacked in off season about how
you wanted them badly LeBron has showed
up for his 21st season to said yo I'm
here and guess what I'm not going
anywhere and guess what I'm G bust all
of y'all you know what if I got help the
help is Anthony Davis second and rebound
and block shot all of that stuff but you
got to show up on a night in Night Out
basis you can't be a roller coaster you
know tonight was my first time seeing
Tyrese hurton and Zion play I talked
about the last second having that look
Zion having that look Tyrese hbert has
that look he's going to compete I know
he's playing against the king tomorrow
but he's he's coming to play tomorrow
Saturday y'all all know about stars and
this is the thing to me it's not just
your talent that defines whether or not
you're a superstar in this league it's
knowing that you're the Marquee and you
embrace it you want it and we don't see
that enough Kenny we don't see that
enough Stephen the one thing there's a
difference between an All-Star and a
superstar yes an Allstar is a guy who
affects the game in three categories
scoring rebound assist let's say a
superstar affects the game in five
categories you have those three you add
leadership and defense so he can do five
or six things and so what happens you
have to do three every night to be a
superstar but you have to it though
to be a but the thing that disappointed
me I I hate when I hear guys who don't
know anything about sports like well we
going to play all the games the same
that's first of all that's a lie you
don't play all the gam but as a great
player
myself man when I played against a bird
Mel Michael car Malone Patrick Yuan Gary
Peyton I was like no I want y'all to be
talking about me y and and what I saw
tonight cuz Shaq say tonight he's just
this is and Mike you said to me earlier
he's just I think this the most
important game in Zion's career and for
him not to show up and not compete not
compete they didn't compete this was a
very disappointing night for me could
this be the game that's that you said
it's could be important game jars can
you change it can you change it and go I
didn't now when I see you next time you
know okay it could be still that it it
could be but the problem I have who in
the
in the Pelicans organization you don't
need that Y no no somebody who he
already owns the organization who in the
organization can challenge him that's my
biggest concern with Zion going for I
understand that but you have to have it
in your heart and in your mind I want to
be the man yeah but sha you said I want
to be the man I want a Max contract but
you have always said people challenge
you that got you going to the next level
you said that yeah but not people in the
organization him you you Ernie dick tell
my guys like Brad Sergeant Philip
Harrison who let me know like hey you
ain't playing hard enough dad I had 28
bro you missed 15 free throws you should
have had 40 you only had nine rebounds
you're not playing hard enough hang up
okay